there is another lot of bullshit in the House of Representatives
what a prank against your own minister
I also think it's a very strange movement
not exactly either
neatly in proportion to the first
room to do this
not really at all no beauty prize
to engage in politics here in this way now
well you can say that
yesterday the VVD did
leader dilan jeso goes
the proposal to repeal the distribution law
to the surprise of the other members of parliament
the law of distribution
can municipalities impose obligations on asylum seekers
to distribute more fairly across all municipalities
but the law is controversial
this is because they will oblige the municipality to do so
this law is already
approved by the House of Representatives before the elections
the law is now awaiting approval by the Senate
yes you goes made the proposal on behalf of the PVV nse and bbw
parties
involved in the cabinet negotiations
and now Jesse Goes thinks that the recent elections
demonstrate that the distribution law
does not fit in with how the Netherlands views migration
in addition,
they do not want to focus on better care
but especially on reducing the flow of asylum seekers
but the first room
does not have to adhere to the proposal at all
suppose it is accepted
Rutte also said that the First Chamber will discuss its own agenda
it's going well so it's not
but who gets screwed the most
first the asylum seekers
to be in Ter Apel
for example,
are in poor living conditions
they spend the night in waiting rooms and are
there are increasing incidents of violence
secondly the border municipalities
the residents of Ter Apel
experienced
nuisance caused by the large influx of asylum seekers
due to the limited reception facilities
I can't do anything else than
see how politics deals with this
but I see and notice
that at least Ter Apel is being abandoned
yes i understand that
and finally the inventor of the VVD distribution law
secretary of state
Erik van Den Burg
he has 1 incredible load
got shit all over him
to get this through
just when it seemed to be working
he is confronted with this again
literal shit
the asylum reception is in 1 vicious circle
Nuisance in Ter Apel deters other municipalities
but distribution of asylum seekers
can solve this problem
the law of distribution
should provide the solution for this
and fortunately that decision now lies with the Senate
not at yes ukus